den Schreck an Silvester hat der kleine
Paul noch lange nicht vergessen mit
dieser konfetti-pistole hatte er sich
selbst ins Gesicht geschossen da hast du
so gehalten
und dann
und was ist dann passiert
doch der Notruf bei der
bereitschaftszentrale im Kreis Stendal
geriet für Opa Herbert zur Nervensache
Minuten in dieser Warteschleife mit dem
Schreinen kleinen Kind die umher Quark
der heult wurde nicht wie es ist
irgendwas wartest du fünf Minuten Zeit
und dann kriegst du zu erfahren ja hier
21 km in Ihrer Nähe ist ein Augenarzt
Bereitschaft und dann fährst du los
von zu Hause in Havelberg in
Sachsen-Anhalt durch dunkle Kurven
Richtung Osterburg zum Augenarzt hier
ist Havelberg und hier ist Osterburg
und normalerweise überquerten dann bei
Sander die Fähre doch an der Fähre über
die Elbe war erstmal Endstation der
Fährmann hatte schon Feierabend 18:00
Uhr den ganzen schleif bis nach
Tangermünde und dann sind wir nach
Osterburg gefahren wir sind knapp einer
Viertelstunde fahren ein 1/4 Stunde
Notfallrettung für ein verletztes Kind
dem kleinen Paul geht es zwar wieder gut
aber solche Beispiele sorgen in
Havelberg für große Unruhe denn das
örtliche Krankenhaus am Dom wurde vor
zweieinhalb Jahren dicht gemacht
unrentabel für den privaten Betreiber
weil es keinerlei Ersatz gibt gehen die
Bürger auf die Straße so wie vor wenigen
Tagen
kämpft der Verein um die große
medizinische Lücke die die Schließung
gerissen hat zu beleidigen die
Initiative Pro Krankenhaus Havelberg
fordert zumindest ein ambulantes
Medizinisches Versorgungszentrum bisher
vergeblich dieses Medizinische
Versorgungszentrum das wurde uns
versprochen von allen Seiten aber dann
wurde erst ein Konzept erstellten halbes
Jahr lang dann hat man gesagt wir haben
keine Ärzte und die Notfallversorgung
die uns die KV hier an die Hand gibt 116
und 17 können sich jetzt total knicken
das funktioniert überhaupt nicht auch
die Johanniter Unfallhilfe in der 6600
Einwohner großen Hansestadt Havelberg
bestätigt die bedenklichen Lücken in der
Notfallversorgung denn es fehlen sogar
an Rettungswagen ab 16 Uhr steht nur
einer zur Verfügung
also wenn man um 17 Uhr ein Herzinfarkt
kriegt und der Rettungswagen ist gerade
unterwegs da ist schlecht wenn man den
Havelberg ist Entschuldigung ja dann
wartet man
auf den nächsten Einsatzbereich das wäre
in dem Fall im Glieds wenn der frei ist
der Rettungswagen ist der nicht frei
dann kommt aus dem anderen Landkreis
eben Bad Wilsnack oder eine Stadtburg
der Rettungswagen mit seiner Besetzung
und das kann bei einem Herzinfarkt
natürlich in
muss man sagen klar
für die Stadt Havelberg muss der
Landkreis Stendal die
Gesundheitsversorgung sicherstellen
politisch verantwortlich Landrat Patrick
Kuhlmann von der SPD ein zugesagtes
Interview sagt er wieder ab der Landrat
bestreitet schriftlich den Anspruch auf
wohnortnah erkrankenhausversorgung es
gäbe Zitat keine gesetzliche
Verpflichtung ein Krankenhaus innerhalb
von 30 Minuten Erreichbarkeit
vorzuhalten dabei gibt es in Deutschland
klare Regeln laut Grundgesetz ist der
Staat verpflichtet ein funktionierendes
Gesundheitssystem zu errichten zuständig
dafür ist der Gemeinsame Bundesausschuss
das höchste Beschlussgremium in der
Selbstverwaltung des Gesundheitswesens
hat klar festgelegt ein Bürger muss eine
Klinik in 30 pkw-fahrzeit Minuten
erreichen können
doch dieses Versprechen steht auf dem
Spiel denn die Pleitewelle der
Krankenhäuser rollt bereits an Beispiel
das katholische St josef-Krankenhaus im
nordrhein-westfälischen Linnich seit
Jahren macht die Klinik Verluste in
Millionenhöhe
dieselben Probleme zwölf Kilometer
weiter in Jülich beim ST
elisabeth-Krankenhaus mit weniger als
200 Betten können die Kleinen Kliniken
ihre Kosten nicht mehr decken seit
Jahren fehlt Geld für teure medizinische
Geräte hinzu kommt der allgemeine
Fachkräftemangel für gut ausgebildetes
Personal ist es hier in der Provinz
unattraktiv
Schuld an der Finanznot der
Krankenhäuser seien die Länder die ihren
Unterhaltspflichten nicht nachkommen
meinen Kritiker die Länder finanzieren
nur etwa die Hälfte der notwendigen
Krankenhaus Investitionen das heißt wir
haben einen zunehmenden Substanz Verfall
in den Krankenhäusern und wir können
unsere Medizintechnik und auch die
bauliche Infrastruktur nicht
modernisieren wir haben große Lücken die
die Krankenhäuser nicht alleine fühlen
können den Bundesgesundheitsminister
bleibt im Januar nichts anderes übrig
als das Scheitern der krankenhauspolitik
einzugestehen die Krankenhäuser sind in
einer Notlage mittlerweile haben 60
Prozent der Krankenhäuser erhebliche
finanzielle Probleme wir haben große
Qualitätsdefizite dahingehend dass
tatsächlich in vielen Krankenhäusern die
medizinischen Geräte die Gebäude aber
auch das Personal nicht mehr ausreicht
um die Leistungen in der Qualität zu
erbringen wie dies notwendig wäre
Lauterbach will das krankenhaussystem
neu organisieren dabei orientierte sich
vor allem an diesem zentralen Gutachten
der Bertelsmann Stiftung von 2019 darin
fordern Gesundheitsökonomen den
Kahlschlag in der Kliniklandschaft eine
bessere Versorgung ist nur mit halb so
vielen Kliniken möglich die aktuell
knapp 1.400 Kliniken müssten auf
deutlich unter 600 Häuser verringert
werden
wir stehen am Vorabend einer notwendigen
Revolution im Krankenhaussektor doch
gegen Lauterbachs Revolution gehen in
ganz Deutschland die Bürger auf die
Straße fürchten eine noch schlechtere
klinikversorgung als bisher
ein Teil dieser krankenhäuser werden zu
ambulanten Gesundheit
szentrum ohne Notfall
Versicherung Bereitschaft ein anderer
Teil der Krankenhäuser sollen nur
Basisversorgung leisten und das heißt
diese krankenhäuser werden in solche
Notfällen wie zum Beispiel ein
Herzinfarkt nicht mal die Erstversorgung
leisten dürfen
besonders dramatisch ist dass die
Geburtskliniken zu etwa die Hälfte
geschlossen werden sollen auch das
Krankenhaus Eckernförde in
Schleswig-Holstein hat kaum
Überlebenschancen seit Dezember ist die
Klinik im Insolvenzverfahren genauso wie
26 km entfernt das Krankenhaus Rendsburg
43 Millionen Euro hat der Landkreis seit
2018 als kommunaler Träger in beide
Häuser investiert
für die Klinik Eckernförde sieht die
Landesregierung keine Chance mehr und
das obwohl in einem Bürgerbegehren 67%
der Wähler vor drei Monaten den
kompletten Erhalt bei der kommunaler
Häuser gefordert haben das sei nicht
mehr bezahlbar meint der Landrat und
schiebt die Verantwortung Richtung
Landesregierung der Kreis darf nicht
einen Klinikbetrieb organisieren der
nicht dem Krankenhausplan des Landes
entspricht das ist die Koks bei dem
gesamten Verfahren Bürgerbegehren
Bürgerentscheid gewesen dass den
Menschen in gewisser Weise suggeriert
wurde das auf Kreisebene politisch über
eine Frage abgestimmt werden kann die
aber gar nicht in der Gestaltungsarbeit
des Kreises liegt am Ende entscheidet
das neue Krankenhaus finanzierungsgesetz
welche Krankenhäuser überleben dürfen
Hightech Medizin in Unikliniken und
große schwerpunktkrankenhäuser sollen
weiter gestärkt werden
viele Bürger fürchten dass die schnelle
Notfallversorgung auf dem Land nicht
mehr sicher ist die Deutsche
Krankenhausgesellschaft hat diese Sorgen
gestern bestätigt und die Pläne der von
Lauterbach eingesetzten
Regierungskommission analysiert dort
heißt es Aussetzen der 30-minuten-reger
also Schluss mit der Garantie der
flächendeckenden schnellen Notfall
Versorgung es werden wahrscheinlich
weniger als die Hälfte der Krankenhäuser
erhalten bleiben nach diesem
Regierungsentwurf und das ist ein
massiver Eingriff der aus unserer sich
die Versorgungssicherheit in Deutschland
nicht mehr gewährleistet
Lauterbachs Revolution in der
Krankenhaus Finanzierung des Jahresmitte
soll er fertig sein der Gesetzentwurf
für organisiertes Klinik Stern
[Musik]